[Music]
the plateau straight on symmetrical way
that wes shoots things feels like a
graphic novel it feels like a
presentation the colors the way he
lights things he has exactly what he
wants in mind and he fools you sometimes
into thinking
that this is so formal the shots are so
formal the the moo camera moves are so
formal it might squash
emotion or it might squash spontaneity
and it has the exact opposite effect
you feel comfortable in his visual style
and you know you're going to be
surprised all the time with whatever
he's doing
when i first read this script
it was clear to me
that every sentence as i read the first
30 pages was an entirely new set
and i
knew right away that that's something
that came from
animation
where every shot is its own set and that
that
kind of attention to microscopic detail
on each shot and each beat of a scene is
something that he was going to bring to
live action for the visual base of the
film the costume and the sets and
everything
it's all from research and how do we
shape the research into our story
because you want to try to give it as
much authenticity as you can
one thing that wes does is he sets up a
library of dvds and blu-rays that we
all access most of them were
films from the nouvelle bog the french
new wave
and a lot of the films i had never seen
before so the first thing i do is try to
immerse myself in the world and then we
had a photographic library as well of
reference photos
from
you know the turn of the century all the
way until the 70s and the way paris
which onwe was
loosely based on and they gave us a good
idea of what wes was going for the
biggest challenge on this movie was
volume actually i mean it because it
wasn't one movie it was you know it's
all these different stories interrelated
and so each one of those stories needed
all of its sets i mean how many sets are
there in this film oh god
a lot i think we're up in the 130
range there's a very long sequence that
we film when we first enter
the police station
that set
is a character
and it's also a film making device it's
almost a piece of the camera in the way
that we use it and in the way that you
know the dolly works through it and so
it's designed uh yes as a backdrop to
the scene and yes as a place but it's
also
designed as a very specific filmmaking
tool for wes anderson
police cooking began with the stakeout
picnic and paddy wagon snack but he's
evolved and codified into something
refined intensely nourishing and if
executed properly marvelously flavorful
the whole idea was to make it a little
bit mysterious at first and we were
shooting black and white and you know
jeffrey wright is kind of
walking through the police station
finally he finds it and our key group
sanjay had set up this amazing dolly
which uh two tracks there's one that
goes in and out and one that goes
sideways and we're switching the dolly
in and out it's a very intricate setup
uh jeffrey wright is is is has a
dialogue throughout this whole thing and
we have to make our moves kind of keyed
by what he's saying obviously
it was a real challenge for us and we
all love doing those kinds of shots when
you can pull it off you really get a
sense of
you know kind of exhilaration
the the bare bones of that set we found
at the felt factory and that became a de
facto like film studio in the center of
town it had three or four warehouses
that where we had a construction shop
model making shop
and a couple of shooting stages where we
could set things up and it really became
an actual film studio totally from
scratch
without even electricity when we walked
in the door adam stockhausen's
set design was so amazing like every
little thing that he got just from my
kitchen
was so
extravagant and detailed and oh like the
the stove and all these kind of ancient
kind of
kitchen tools
were everywhere
that was a wonderful location it was in
france and so there was a wealth of
amazing
french things to buy for these sets so i
found all of the copper cookware and the
ovens and all of the
just anything i could possibly want was
at a flea market and i would go once a
month and bring all of that in with
melano the costume designer color
becomes such a key part of how the story
is told you know and just making sure
that those things balance out together
and come out the way that wes is
expecting is a constant process together
elena i mean what's to say she's
incredible
you you show up and you're wearing your
t-shirt and your sweater and your pants
and it's like
what amazing thing are they going to
turn us into today and melania and wes
communicate almost silently and
invisibly but they so understand what
they want he wants to work with
filmmakers and someone like milena
makes the films that she works on as
much as the director does as much as
anybody who's designing
or photographing or in the film
each character is so distinct so
spot on according to her sensibilities
and west's sensibilities
rolling
freeze
sanjay
the key grip sanjay sami who i believe
started working with west on darjeeling
limited he gave me this new appreciation
for
dollywork working the way west works the
artistic precision is so important and
something that i was very inspired by so
when i watch now one of west's film i
can feel the emotional investment of the
movement of the camera i've sat in on
dinner time conversations between wes
and sanjay when they have been
discussing a shot which is seemingly
impossible and
sanjay
will eat his dinner and go okay leave it
with me i'm gonna figure it out and he
does and that is a massive massively
important collaboration they're
reinventing the wheel all the time
[Music]
this film is very much in love with
creativity it's in love with artistry
and
this is i think west's forte is just the
attention to detail
[Music]
we always say we can't understand how he
manages to do it but this one is really
truly something else
kind of blown away when i saw the movie
like how did he do it
i remember when i first started doing
movies
which sort of can we do this
we have a great group of people and i
don't feel like i even bother to say
that anymore
[Music]